[Music]
our series what's new and 22 looks at
the stories and the trends that will
define the year to come this morning we
turn to politics president biden's first
year in office was dominated by the
pandemic and its impact on the economy
rising inflation and supply chain
problems that cause widespread shortages
also a big item on the president's
agenda his build back better plan is
still undone so what should we expect in
22 well cbs news political contributors
joel payne and leslie sanchez join us to
talk about this joel's a democratic
party strategist leslie is a republican
strategist good morning good to see you
both
yeah good morning
all right joel let's start with you uh
build back better is in the balance
how should democrats regroup next year
to get this done
well obviously uh built back better is
going to look different after the new
year we all saw the news of senator
manchin
you know sharing publicly his concerns
about the size of the package and the
amount of the package i think you'll see
a scaled back buildback better bill i
think it'll still be significant and
it'll be something that democrats can
sell but it's not going to be as massive
as the progressive base may have wanted
if you look at 2021
president biden really struggled off
schedule
the first part of the year was
completely on schedule he was able to
predict all the responses needed related
to covet and all of the things that were
gonna reign over the first six months of
his presidency but the second part of
the year afghanistan rising consumer
cost
all of the minutia have built back
better in the infrastructure bill
leaking out into the public those are
the off-schedule things that i think the
president and the white house struggled
with and i think going into 2022 you're
going to see them try to rebound and get
things back on track
so let's let's talk republicans when you
hear kevin mccarthy the minority leader
he's confident that republicans are
going to win back the house
what is the message though that
republicans are running on is it
do we still see folks that want to be
like former president trump or is there
still an anti-trump or a more
conservative republican strain through
the party that thinks that they can win
yeah i'm glad you start there vlad a big
part of the movement and what you're
hearing on capitol hill is there's
they're saying with biden administration
you have a crisis of confidence
confidence in being able to move through
successfully the covenant 19 crisis and
pandemic there was an expectation that
this cooling period of a different style
of leadership under biden would allow
for a very clear understanding of next
steps of how to handle variants but even
the the denial rejection of increasing
and ramping up testing for example in
preparation for a holiday surge in
preparation for increase in variance and
where a lot of americans fundamentally
feel they're stuck right back where they
started this mercurial electorate is
going to continue to swing back until
they find
confidence in leadership and that's
where mccarthy and a lot of republicans
are seeing some daylight every day they
tell me they're increasing their
optimism they have 23 democrats right
now that have announced their retirement
they expect more and the bigger issue
for republicans they're looking at that
redistricting mac republicans
have control of at least 20 states if
you include
kind of their redistricting control and
independent commissions that are
appointed by republican legislatures
compared to a very just a handful of
democrats that's nearly 200 seats that
they're they're redrawing so with that
confidence uh crisis
with this increase in inflation joel
talked about and the new redistricting
republicans see it as a very good time
uh leading into 2022.
joel back to you what does president
biden and the democrats need to do to
avoid major midterm losses
well nate um look history says they're
gonna lose seats um even in the best of
circumstances again i worked a decade
ago on the first two years of the obama
administration in congress and it was
one of the most productive congresses of
all time it was uh you know close to the
great society in terms of productivity
and democrats still lost that midterm
midterms are designed for the incumbent
party to lose and so there is an
inevitability to that that i think most
political parties understand i do think
however the president and his party do
have a chance to get their feedback
under them you pass this bill back
better bill you spend the next 11 months
selling infrastructure selling bill beck
better talking about the change that
you've brought
to the american people and also creating
that contrast between a biden version of
america and the version of america that
was voted out 11 months ago with donald
trump that's your best chance to hold on
to power but again they're fighting an
uphill battle and a lot of wind in their
face
speaking of donald trump leslie i want
to get to you you got about 30 seconds
do you think republican candidates will
be loyal to the former president donald
trump or do you think they're going to
back another candidate
jamie follow the money right so in
increasingly
in some places trump can continue have
to have uh be an effective person in
raising money and kind of mobilizing the
popular space however you're starting to
see people pull away independently
particularly governors who've had some
success by pushing against biden
administration um and it's some of the
tenants the themes populist themes but
not donald trump directly
joel payne and leslie sanchez thank you
so much